I figured out the simplest scalping
strategy that turns losing traders into
profitable ones. Not only has this
strategy worked for me, but it's also
worked for other traders who have tried
it out and they have turned into being
consistent over the long run. I've
compiled a ton of real trade examples.
So, by the end of this video, you will
know exactly how to execute this
strategy just like these other
profitable traders. To give you a super
quick overview before we dive into the
nuts and bolts of how you can
consistently execute this pattern
yourself every day, all I do is when the
US market opens, I look at the first 30
to 60 minutes. All I'm looking for is a
clean support and resistance level and
then I look for a few key patterns. For
example, right here, there's a nice
double top. All I do then is I see a
nice candlestick pattern and then I
enter in on a trade short, betting that
the market is going to go down. And then
from there, I let the market play out.
I've noticed over time that the market
consistently has a reversal in the first
30 to 60 minutes of a trading day. And
so what this strategy does is it allows
you to take advantage of that reversal.
And then coupling that with looking for
key areas of resistance or support,
you're able to essentially pingpong the
market between those levels, capturing a
big potential profit for a smaller
amount of risk. And this is all I do
every day. This is the only thing I look
for every single day. And it allows my
trading to be super simple and
straightforward so that you can go into
every day with a plan and know how to
execute it instead of what I did before
when I was unprofitable. I was trying to
match what the market was doing. And
that just was not profitable. And I know
from teaching a ton of people how to do
this, that's the exact same way they
feel as well. Let me walk you through
how I entered and found this trade. And
so initially what I'm seeing is you can
see that the market had a nice
methodical trend up here and then this
bearishness right here showed me that
okay something's changed. We've broken
this uptrend. That's a massive thing
that I like to look for. And then also
this big trend line right here is drawn
from a bigger picture where on a 15 or 5
minute I can see that the market
consistently is coming up to this level.
It comes up here again it's likely to
continue lower. Obviously, if I see the
threeline strike pattern that I like to
see and a couple of other factors and so
seeing that it had this big bearishness
here, that was a great confirmation to
say, okay, the momentum in this market
is switching. You always want to take
that into account. We came down here,
had a little bit of a bounce, showed,
you know, some momentum. Essentially,
you could even say this is a 50%
pullback from this area. You can see
it's literally in the middle of that
box. The market likes to do pullbacks
like that that are literally halfway of
the move it just had. And so it moved
down this far. It pulled back halfway.
That's what this little spike here is.
And then it sold off. And for me, this
isn't a super picture perfect and really
nice looking threeline strike pattern.
But for me, I saw, you know, okay,
there's some movement up here. There's
this big attempt to go higher and then,
you know, it's essentially in this
little mini channel and then this big
candlestick here. especially with the
fact that it wicks higher right here.
This little wick right here, it's it's
essentially like a micro double top and
then I get in, you know, I I actually
got in down here a little bit because it
was moving pretty quickly. But the
signal there is at the candlestick close
right there. And so that's what I used
to jump in on this and then of course
put the stop up here. Doesn't need to go
all the way up here above this trend
line. You know what we're trying to do
is risk a tight amount and then have the
big picture potential for the market to
really start moving in our favor. And so
in this trade I think I'm risking like
$500. But you know that's why you can
use this kind of in any account size.
You can scale it up because again
trading super scalable. You just use and
find one pattern that works and then
increase the money. You don't need to
try and find more patterns to make more
trades. That's what kind of kept me from
being profitable initially. And so
you'll see here actually once the market
essentially made a pullback here right
here and then moved down, I moved my
stop loss to break even because I want
to kind of tighten up the trade and get
out if it's going to pull back on me.
You know, sometimes the market's just
going to be choppy and all over the
place. I don't want to trade in that. I
want to be in trades and I've noticed
these trades will work out pretty
cleanly in your favor if they're going
to work out. And so from there, you
know, it starts moving down pretty
quickly. I'm trying to see, okay, is
there this downtrend line that I can
kind of expect the market to pull back
to? And again, that's kind of thinking
about, okay, how am I managing this? You
know, as you are trading, you want to be
thinking what to do next based on logic,
not okay, I'm up, you know, almost
$3,000.
Uh, you know, I'm really nervous. This
is a lot of money. I need to get out or
what if this keeps going, I could be up
5,000, 10,000, right? You can't let your
emotions kind of control you. you need
to have a logical plan to trade with.
And so once this kind of got rocketing
in one direction, it gets really far
away from the trend line. And I don't
want to hold through a pullback. You
know, at this point, that's a big
pullback to hold through for it breaking
that trend line. And so I start using
kind of more of a tighter trailing
stop-loss with kind of previous
candlestick highs. And you can also see
there is this blue box down here. That's
a support level. And so big picture,
I've looked at, okay, well, the market's
already bounced here a couple times. If
we come down here again, I'm going to
expect that we're going to bounce or
slow down. And this is a really fast
moving, unhealthy move, which is great
to be in if you're in it, but it's
likely to snap back at some point. And I
want to be out when it's going to snap
back. And so that's why I have kind of a
tighter trailing stop-loss. And you can
see it's starting to snap back a little
bit. And I want to give it a little
wiggle room because, you know, these
things can break through a support level
and keep going lower. But in this case,
it kind of starts to chop here. It makes
a double bottom and it essentially
knocks me out here. But I get, you know,
about $3,500, $3,200 worth of profit.
So, now that you have a good
understanding of what I look for every
trade, I want to zoom through a couple
more trade entries so you can get this
repetition down. Because at the end of
the day, trading is very repetitive, but
it's all slightly different. Every trade
entry has something slightly different
about it. There's going to be something
different to learn and take away from
every different trade entry. So, when
you try and do this yourself, you have
that pattern recognition in your mind.
We're going to jump into one more pretty
in-depth walkthrough so you really have
a good understanding of the trade
entries. And then also I'm going to show
you a couple trades of doing this on a
small account. You can do this starting
with $50 to $100. I had a whole
challenge where I took $50 and turned it
into over $3,000 using this strategy.
And now, let me kind of give you a deep
dive into the checklist I use for each
one of these trade entries and how to
know why the fair value gap is going to
really reverse versus, you know, before
a lot of people will try and see that
fair value gap and kind of buy here
looking for it to go long. And sometimes
that'll happen and I'll avoid those
trades because of a few key factors. You
need just the basics of this fair value
gap to be popping off. And the biggest
thing is having a bunch of them compared
to the trade today I took. That'll
really increase your confidence because
when the market whips up that high that
fast, it's really likely to give it back
up because of remember that imbalance in
the market. That's what really makes
this so powerful and allows you to when
you trade to enter in and risk a smaller
amount or have a good riskreward ratio
to where you can be risking, you know,
$100, $1,000, doesn't matter what your
size is, but you're going for three
times your risk. That's a massive key
when it comes to trading. For me, I have
found that's way easier to be successful
at. And so, kind of the first thing is
you want those fair value gap
indicators. And then second is coming up
to this resistance zone. You have to
have a key level to be trading these off
of. You do not want to be just trading
them randomly. Here's a clean example of
really just right before this trade
happened is where there's this is big
indicator of overextension, right? But
you can see there is if we kind of zoom
out, there's not really a good clean
level. There's kind of something here,
but if you really zoom out, that's
middle of the range. They're good
extreme levels down here. I I'm not
going to go over how to draw key levels
in this video. I'll link a video up here
on how to do that properly, but that is
why and a reason why you want to stay
from away from something like this
because there isn't a good zone to
reverse off of. You need to be waiting
for there to be a really clean zone like
this. and then going into a one minute
chart because I like to trade on a one
minute chart right when the market
opens. I'll take a fiveminute entry a
little later sometimes or if the
market's a little slower, but in this
case I took it on a 1 minute because it
made a really nice setup. Now another
huge factor in this trade is there was
timing. I have three kind of timing
windows I look for and the window this
one aligned up was 30 minutes after the
market opens. I constantly see reversals
happen at that time. And so this is a
another catalyst on what makes this a
really good setup. And then kind of the
final thing is you know you have this
uptrend that's broken but a big thing is
looking at the structure of the highs
and the lows. the swings. And so here,
you know, in an uptrend, it's making
higher highs and higher lows. And so I
need to see that stop and it make a
lower high. This is a massive key factor
here. And so from that point, that's
when I look to jump in the trade.
Sometimes I'll look and say, okay, I
like a five minute better, but the five
minute kind of just chopped here pretty
good, too. So when I was actually
trading this, this took a long time to
get going. On a fivem minute, it looks
pretty simple. But on a one minute, it
took about 20 30 minutes to get going.
And when I was trading larger than
normal size, I put $1,400 of risk on
this trade. My kind of normal large size
is a,000. And because this was such a
good setup, I did a little extra because
of how confident I was in it. And so it
makes just the waiting even that much
worse. And so eventually though, it
punched down here, moved to break even,
and set a limit order here at two times
my risk. Essentially, a good target is
the bottom of the main move. That's the
easy money if you ask me. And then after
that, my thought was, okay, I will trail
this thing and let it keep going if it's
going to keep going. But if it has a big
pullback like it just did, I'm going to
get out and call it a day. And so the
first thing of course is using those two
indicators is to see that we're coming
up into a key resistance zone. Again,
you can draw these yourself based on
that other video or I do have an
indicator that does it pretty well
automatically. And the second thing, of
course, is this move was overextended
based on the other overextension
indicator. So you have those two keys
showing up showing you that this has a
high probability to reverse. That is the
biggest confidence booster when it comes
to trade. And this is what honestly
helps me focus on the process as much as
possible is always making sure that you
have those two keys in place before you
even sit down and consider taking a
trade. It helps you just avoid all the
noise when it comes to trading. And so
that's the honestly the first thing in
the checklist is having a key reversal
zone and having an overextension
indicator signal come up. The next thing
is having a key reversal pattern. What I
like to do is look for either a double
top or a head and shoulders or even in
this case it did essentially a fail
breakout here where it broke above the
previous extreme high. got a lot of
people in excited thinking it was going
to go higher and then it reversed. And
so this candlestick right here gave me a
ton of confidence. And then the final
confirmation was that it had this little
pullback here and then pushed lower with
this big candlestick confirming a lot of
momentum to the downside. And that is
where I essentially entered in on my
trade and then used my riskreward
calculator tool here to put my stop loss
up here and target a certain amount of
risk. You want to try and keep your risk
the same every time. And then as this
moves in my favor, you know, I slowly
move my stop losses down. And usually
the initial target I have for these
trades is if it gives back up that
overextended move. But you always want
to try and let it run a little bit more
just in case it's going to keep going
farther. So this trade right here had a
pretty big spike down and I closed out
right here for pretty much $2,000 in
under 15 minutes in the morning. Here's
another example and this is on the flip
side looking for a long. You can see
clearly I'm looking at a support level
here where the market's bounced once,
twice. There was probably another bounce
here before on the previous area in the
chart that I was looking at. And so I'm
already looking for the big picture of
the market to come down here and bounce.
And to accurately enter and confirm that
the market's going to bounce here is I
looked for the market to make a
essentially it slowed down here and then
it had a strong bullish candlestick here
form and I got in essentially as it was
about to finish closing. I got in a
couple seconds earlier, but I
essentially got in as it created that
threeline strike pattern. And you can
see here, it was actually a candlestick
after the bottom here. It wasn't right
away, but it was still showing me that
switch in momentum, and it gave me an
accurate entry to enter in at the bottom
of the swing, have a tighter stop-loss,
and then capture the reversal back
higher. And so this is super super
powerful for capturing trades like this.
You know, every trade is going to go
slightly different. We're going to go
over that massive one here in a minute,
but this is still a really nice trade to
capture, you know, $4 $500 worth of
profit. Again, just trading 60 minutes
in the morning. And so at that point,
you know, the market kind of slowed
down. I said, "Okay, I want to get out
if it breaks lower because it could just
give that swing back up." And that's
where I kind of got out at about $400
and moved on with my day. Now, this is a
good example of a trade on a small
account. I'm kind of doing a small
account challenge right now. And this is
on a small account. And so, I'm risking
$100 here, betting that the market is
going to reverse off of this resistance
level that I've drawn. And then, you
know, betting it to go probably kind of
down here. And we'll talk about targets
and why that's a good target later. But
if it gets down there, that's a good
two, three times my risk. And on a small
account risking $100, that is a nice
profit. And so the first thing that I'm
looking for obviously is that it comes
up to that level first, right? That is
the number one key thing to make
reversal trading work is the patience to
just wait for the market to come to an
extreme and key level. You can even see
the market came here and reversed off of
this little area right here. You can
say, well, you know, it bounced here, it
bounced here, it bounced here, and so
maybe it bounces here. Maybe I should
have got that. You know, maybe you even
look at hindsight and say, "Oh, I'll try
and get that next time." But those don't
work very often, and they're more likely
to cause you to lose money in the long
run. It's better to just sit out, kill
that noise, and wait for the market to
come to these extremes. And then when
it's oversold or overbought in this
case, you can capture on that strong
reversal to the downside. And so, the
first key that I like to use is after
it's kind of hit that level, again, you
can see it's not quite in my zone, but
again, it's so close, it's good enough.
The first thing is making sure that
uptrend is broken. Because when you're
counter trend trading, you don't want to
go against a trend because, you know, it
might come up to a level here, but it's
in an uptrend and it's just going to
keep going, right? We don't know. These
these levels aren't going to hold every
time. It's not just blindly sell or buy
at these levels. And so, that's kind of
why I have this uptrend here is you can
see that we had strong bullish
candlesticks here and then it it kind of
started to break is it had a dogey here.
It had a bearish candle here and then it
made kind of another push higher. And so
for me, that's good enough to say, hey,
yeah, this strong kind of micro trend
right here is broken. And you can see
the market's kind of being quick with
its reversals. And so I'm okay with
thinking that that's a a good enough
trend break. Certain kind of trends,
they'll need something else. But in this
case, for this kind of very one
directional unhealthy trend, it's good
in terms of clearing that kind of need
for a reversal break. And so after that,
my next key that I like to look for is
kind of a reversal pattern or reversal
candlestick pattern. And so in this
case, the market started to show some
weakness here with this kind of dogee
here and this kind of red bar. and it
broke that uptrend and then it made
these two candlesticks here, these
bullish candlesticks breaking this
previous high. This high right here
became a new one. And for me, that said,
okay, it's still going higher. But as
soon as this big bearish candlestick
form right here, this big red one, that
to me is showing it almost made a a
micro failed breakout. It made that kind
of trap where it attempted to make a new
high and it it did it made us a new high
but barely at all. You know, it didn't
make much before this big bearish
candlestick came in. And so, if I kind
of zoom back in the recording and kind
of show you that in real time right now,
to speed this up a little, once this
candlestick finishes forming, I think
that's a a good signal for me. And I
want to get in right there at the low of
that candle. So, my thought is, okay, I
want to get in when it kind of breaks
the low of this candle because to me,
that's a strong enough signal that it's
likely going to reverse there. And so,
you can see initially it kind of starts
to go against me and doesn't look great
initially, but you know, that's where
when things reverse, sometimes they take
a little while. The market won't always
just reverse on a dime. A lot of times
it'll come up like it did, kind of start
to settle down and slow and lose some of
that momentum and strength and then
it'll give it back up and start going.
And so that's what I'm kind of looking
for. And so for once I entered in there,
I moved my stop above this high because
the whole idea is if it comes up here
and knocks me out, you know, I'm looking
for that kind of quick reversal to fail.
And I think if it comes up here, comes
back down and and keeps going higher, I
think that's a stronger uptrend. It's
had a healthy pullback if it does that
and then it keeps going higher and you
know I I want to get out. The idea is
with trading is you take your stabs,
they either work out really quickly and
really well right away or they just
don't work out and you move on. If
you're trying to force a trade in
conditions where it's just not great and
not working out, you're going to lose
money if you try and enter in the market
over and over.
And a lot of the times when the market
has a big move like this, kind of like
we were talking about earlier, that it's
a big area where the market velocity off
that area was really big. It's more
likely that when the market comes back
down there, it's going to find a bounce
and it's going to find some buyers and
support. And this trade right here is
going to dry up and slow down. And I
want to capture my profits here because
I'm getting, you know, about two two and
a half times my risk on this trade. And
that is a great trade to just
consistently make money and grow your
trading account. And again, that's what
you want to start out with. You don't
want to be trying to get home runs, make
a ton of money. Make your small account
grow over time. And then this you can
10x this size. I have trades on my
channel where this trade would be
$2,000. And it's the exact same setup.
And so actually at that point you can
see I had my stop loss down there
because I was managing it pretty tight
because we got down to this area and it
closed out there and it actually started
to reverse and you can see it started to
reverse off that level. So now that
we've mainly focused and you have a good
understanding of entries, what you need
to learn now is how to manage the
trades. I have a couple different styles
of how I manage them and you'll start to
understand them throughout this section.
It can either be going for a fixed
profit target or managing the trade
fluidly. This is really important to get
down and understand because the entries
are the most important part, but being
able to maximize how much you're getting
from every trade is very important for
your long-term profitability. And so
essentially at this point, this is where
I'm thinking, okay, I want to see a
large candlestick here form because
that's going to help me with step three
and four. Basically, it's going to show
me a double bottom and then it's also
going to be that strong engulfing
candlestick that confirms that. And so,
right here, you can see I'm I'm using
essentially a tool to say, okay, if I
enter here and my stop loss is here, how
much do I want to enter in on the trade?
And then where is, you know, my
riskreward ratio is going to be. And so
essentially once I wait for that to
confirm, I like to let the next
candlestick play out a little bit
because sometimes a big candlestick like
that can have a little of a bit of a
pullback before it keeps going higher.
Minor detail, but essentially what I'm
looking for now is okay, I'm going to
enter in long at the break of this
pattern and as it goes higher. And so
what I do is you actually see there's no
order here on the screen, but I've
entered in a long here and put my stop
loss down here. The only reason why it
doesn't show up is actually just because
my account on this recording screen
wasn't selected for a little while. But
if we zoom forwards, you can see I
entered in here and I put my stop loss
below here. Essentially the bottom of
that swing. The whole idea of why I put
my stop loss there is because I don't
want the market to if the market comes
up here, makes a pretty clean higher low
and then comes up and breaks that. I
think the trend's going to continue
lower. And so I just want to kind of get
out because I'm getting mixed signals. I
want the signals for the trade to be
clear and for me to jump in on the
trade. And so with with this trade, I
think I'm risking about $800. And so as
we move up, I'm looking at a few key
factors to manage it. And so to walk you
through how I plan to do this is well
obviously the major swing I'd love to go
for is somewhere up here. That would be
holding overnight multiple days and
that's not really what I was looking for
today especially because it's a Friday.
It's going into a long weekend actually
with a holiday on Monday. Now, obviously
you didn't know that, but just looking
at the patterns here is well, the
market's starting to kind of slow down.
And so, there's potential resistance
zones here where I think the market
could slow down. I also think a big
picture kind of more looking at a 30
minute is if we look at this, well, the
major kind of swing down it had when it
started to accelerate was kind of this
area right here. And so I would think a
good spot would be to give uh back up to
here if it really started to get going.
And so that's essentially what I'm doing
every time I'm in a trade is I'm
thinking about where are the potential
for not necessarily major. You don't
necessarily need to be targeting a major
swing or a major supply or demand level,
but also looking at these smaller ones
because now that we're in a trade, those
can still reverse the market. They're
not necessarily where I want to enter in
on the market, but they are at a spot
where I want to potentially get out or
take some of the trade off. And so right
here, you can see as the market started
to push up here, it's had a really nice
move. It's essentially given up this
major move down. I have moved my trade
to break even. It's really important to
take that risk off the table because
going forwards, well, I don't want it to
come up here all the way down and I
actually end up losing $800 on the day
when I was up over $800. That's just
kind of, you know, mathwise, you got to
kind of go with that. And the helpful
part is it had this little micro
pullback here. That's when I kind of
moved it up. And then from there in a
minute here, I put in a limit order at
this high here because I wanted to say I
don't want to manage it in real time. I
want to just get out of half of my trade
of one of my contracts out of my two
when it punches up to this level. And so
right there you can see it closed. And
so I closed off, took about half my
profits there. And then with the idea is
that I'm buying at the major support
here. I want to see if this will
continue higher and I can get even more
out of this, but I don't want to be
greedy. It's at a definite spot where I
think it can slow down. And so I want to
take some off. And so that limit order
that just showed up there, I put it up
here in case we did just skyrocket up
there. That was the spot I wanted to
take the trade off. At that point, I
would have been super happy. I think it
would have been four times my risk in
terms of profit at least for half of
that trade. But going back to the
concepts that we talked about, you can
see I have a trend line here. And this
upwards trend that is going on here is a
very unhealthy or onedirectional trend.
And so my thought is I'm okay holding
this as long as it holds this trend
line. But as soon as it kind of starts
to break that, it could pull back in a
big way. And at this point, I'm thinking
that, hey, this is a great move. I don't
want to hold through a big pullback. and
push higher. I was able to break up my
trade into maybe having a smaller amount
on here. And so at this point, I was
essentially just watching this and
saying, "Okay, I'm going to get out."
And so, just to zoom forwards here, is
it had a little bit of a bottom here,
moved my stop loss up there, and then it
eventually broke that right there. And
so, that's how I take this whole process
and turn it into a step-by-step
checklist that you can now use for
yourself. And to help you consistently
execute this strategy, I've created a
free 14page guide that'll walk you
through the major patterns that I use to
look for reversals, look to enter in on
my trades for confirmation every time I
look for this strategy. You can download
it in the link in the description of
this video or using this QR code is I
want to see the market kind of start to
show kind of a bottoming pattern right
here. It's basically making higher
highs. And so I like this as this
candlestick was a really kind of a big
bearish candlestick attempting the
market to go lower and it failed here
based on these candlesticks. And so I
like the idea of saying, "Hey, I want to
get in long above this candlestick right
here betting that the market is going to
go higher." And so I put what is called
a buy stop order above it. If the price
of the market touches this price, put in
a market order. I don't care where you
feel me at, just get me in the market.
And most of the time you can see it
literally just filled it at that exact
price. But sometimes it can, you know,
fill you right here because the market
can move pretty fast. But that is the
order I like to enter in on most of the
time. And you know, you can use a buy
limit order that will get you in below
or exactly at that price. But the
problem with that is well for this
example right here well the market kind
of took off here and you would have felt
a lot of FOMO and you would have because
you would have missed out on the trade
and you would have had to wait for and
hope that the market comes back down and
fills you at that price. And so you can
see here quickly just over a couple
candlesticks I'm already up $1,000 on
this trade risking you know I think $500
or $600. And so this is where the power
comes into play is I'm trading four oil
futures contracts here. And you can see
it's moving in that 0.01
increment, that penny size, compared to
the S&P 500 futures that we're just
looking at was actually moving in that
quarter of a point size, that 0.25. But
you can see here clearly that the money
is a lot more. And so for me, my
strategy is I like to kind of get in
when I see, you know, basically you can
easily see here is there's a lot of
momentum here. It started to slow down
by essentially just seeing that the
market kind of started chop here. And
then I look for a couple few key factors
to jump in and catch the momentum to the
other side. And so I move my stop here
to break even. And then as this starts
to kind of get pretty accelerated here,
I like to use kind of the idea that,
hey, okay, I'm gonna give it a little
bit of wiggle room, but I'm going to
move my stop up if it pulls back
because, you know, I'm up about $2,000.
And, you know, you want to let this
thing run if it's going to run. But you
also, you know, you can see like just as
it pulled back right here, it can
reverse very, very quickly, too. And so
that's where I really look to, you know,
manage my trades. But again, that's come
with a lot of practice and experience
trading this. You know, my target here,
you can see now that we're getting up to
here. You can see we're kind of in a
support level that I've drawn from
previously in the chart and that's where
I'm going to expect things to slow down.
And so, you can see I've moved my stop
loss up here. It's, you know, we're up a
lot more money now. And this is where
kind of the power comes into play of
using technical analysis with futures is
you have that leverage and you have that
ease of getting in and out of the
market, but you also have the simplicity
of, you know, you're not having to deal
with the complexity of options and other
factors that come into play with other
assets. And so to just to close this
out, you know, I'm not going to go into
my strategy too much here. I have a lot
more videos on that, but I pretty much
get knocked out right there. So, now
that you know pretty much the nuts and
bolts of this strategy, I want to show
you some live trading examples. These
are recordings of trades I took and me
in real time, not just kind of going
back over and kind of explaining a trade
I took in the past. This is what it's
like in real time. This is super
powerful for you to now understand what
it's like showing up to the morning,
analyzing the market as I see it in real
time, entering a trade, managing a
trade, and going through the emotions
and how I control the emotions and don't
let them control me for a trade and to
be consistently doing this every single
day. Okay. Well, it's time to lock in.
The market is seriously moving this
morning.
uh 15-minute chart of NASDAQ. We're
coming up to basically I think that's
pretty much all-time highs. ES is not
quite there, but it's a previous high.
And then
um also we have oil here
is doing a pretty big selloff
kind of just back down to this kind of
support area. Um, so I like it for a
bounce off of this big move down. Uh, I
would like a double bottom though to
some extent. It does have news
right here.
Um, so
we'll see if that sets something up.
Mainly, honestly, what I'm looking at is
this NASDAQ
move right now is pretty crazy. Um,
we've got news at 8.
Not big news honestly. Uh the 8:30 is
oil. These are you know not west coast
times. Then FOMC
is in in a while. So this move will be
done by then.
Um so I just want to see if it kind of
looks like it's going to reverse here at
kind of 45 or 8 a.m. kind of quick early
morning reversal.
See what happens.
Just going to quickly let my room know
what I'm thinking.
I would prefer a five minute, but like
big picture, this is a nice
spot. I really like
that we are at the all-time highs here.
It is a lot of movement strength. I mean
this is broken
but the main thing is that there's
the fair value gap is basically saying
hey it's super overextended.
It's super overextended into sorry
smaller chart into that previous high.
I mean even a pullback down to like here
somewhere is great.
It's 54.
This news coming out is
let's see pull up this
tool I have. Let's see. It's a wholesale
inventories. So, it
top of the hour wholesale inventories
is not a big release. So, it shouldn't
really matter that much and I can
actually trade through the release.
Um, so that's kind of important to know.
If this sets up beforehand, I can pretty
much say I'll just get in anyway.
So, I might enter in the ES instead.
This move back up a lot more. Which one
is up?
So, NASDAQ is up8 this morning while the
ES is up 6. So, it's definitely moving
more,
but I would I would I would like to
trade the weaker one because that's
generally the better way to go.
A little bit more of a pullback than
this.
Um 2 minutes on the news.
That's right there.
Just trying to take
I do want to full size this actually
because this is a really nice move
at a good area.
Um
gold actually looks strong. This is gold
on a 15minute. Gold looks like it's
going to bottom
and it's somehow showing strength when
the market is showing strength and so
I think that's kind of helpful for this.
Okay, news is popping up after this
candlestick here.
Um, oil is still kind of doing its
thing. I'm not really concerned about
that right now. I'd rather focus on
this.
Comparing these two, still
NASDAQ is showing
still more strength while the ES is
showing more weakness.
I do want to be aware that this could
just pull back and shoot continue to
shoot higher. But
again, I want to be aware that that's
okay.
I still want to jump in when a good
signal shows up because
um it's at a good area that makes sense.
You know, I don't know what the market's
going to do. Obviously, I just want to
jump in when it makes sense.
like this is a nice little stab higher.
ENQ's actually making a new high. Wow.
While ES is not.
So, I think if
NQ looks like it's going to fail,
that's what I want to jump in on.
like this if this fails
like putting in an order below this low
because on a five minute I think that
would still look pretty good on a five
minute
because also big picture if I pull up
targets for this potential.
I mean, it's the the easy money would be
giving this move back up, but then we
could push lower to here, which would be
like this is 3x. This would be like 6x.
Um,
which would be obviously a sick move.
I don't think that's super likely, but
Wow. So, that does look good.
I do want to get in short if it but
All right. Like I think I want to get
short here.
It's just a little nerve-wracking with
the NQ being.
But again, like that was a fast move up.
So, I'm nervous about this. But again,
the reasons to get in are good.
NASDAQ,
it could have just got, you know, this
could just be like a final push higher
that fails.
This candlestick right here is pretty
strong. It's just a
an an attempt in a new high and then
it's gonna fail.
I would like to see how this does this
kind of bottom here and then continue
higher,
but I think if the NASDAQ gives up, this
is going to push lower.
So, I think I'm going to put in an order
below this.
It's a good setup. New high, lower high.
Big picture is good.
And I'm going to put my stop above the
highs
and I'm going to manage
accordingly.
Um,
nice failure there. Again, like the big
thing is this could just come down and
bottom and continue higher.
So,
this point. Just kind of let it do its
thing.
See how it plays out again like this
looking even on a five minute. That's a
nice fivem minute candle.
Um
but we'll see what it does. Also, if
you're wondering what trading platform
I'm using, it's called Ninja Trader.
I've used it for over 5 years. It's
amazing. I'll leave a link in the
description below this video if you want
to check it out. Okay, I think this is
not going to work cuz let's be honest,
your trades never work.
But it looks good. It looks good in all
reality.
That's a nice little poke higher.
Um, let's look at what
gold looks good.
Pray the gold goes up. That'll help.
Oil.
I don't like oil for I suck at oil
longs, honestly.
And when I look at it, this is just I
think FOMO over seeing this move. really
the sick entry was this bar right here
and catch that move down otherwise it
was just not worth it.
Um, so I mean like if it bounces, but
it's got it's got news in 20 minutes, so
unlikely.
Again, it's pretty nerve-wracking
cuz there could be just a lot of
strength here and it could just
uh
continue up.
But again, the main thing is it's all
about just following your plan because
this doesn't have to work in every time.
Even if it works 50% of the time and I
get 2x or a little bit off one, like
it's great.
And this still is setting up.
It's still at a decision point. Not out
of the woods, but I think ES looks good.
I'm going to sit on a five minute.
See what that looks like.
I'm gonna move it. It's It was not in a
good spot to be frank.
The reason why I like it to be above the
high because if the market came up here
and like let's say
reversed
right here, knocked me out, but then did
a big bar down, I would still want to be
in, but I would have been out of the
trade. Like, it's not violated until it
breaks up here.
It can come up here and then do a failed
breakout back, failed selloff back in,
but usually that's unlikely.
So, this
is not selling off quickly. I would say
it doesn't look good.
I think if this
lower high here on the NASDAQ doesn't
turn into head and shoulders and start
going down, I'm going to want to get out
cuz at that point it just looks like
it's probably going to continue higher.
I'm just going to go step away for a
while cuz this is driving me a little
crazy
and I think it's going to not work out
even though NQ is actually making more
lows.
NQ looks better
than the ES now. But
this trading, we got to sit here in the
agony
of indecision.
I think because of it being kind of like
this once it gets to break even or 1x I
think I'm going to go break even
unless it just gets moving quickly.
This is when just looking at a a bigger
picture five minute chart just makes it
way easier to
to drown out the noise.
of it
looking good or or looking bad.
We're just looking for a push. Of
course, the NASDAQ is now selling off
better.
Classic. You choose one and the other is
better. Um,
now I'll just turn this on to for kicks.
I want to move to break even now because
if it just shoots up after that, I'm
just going to get out. Like, just get me
out of that. Um, I'm going to take off
2x for sure
down here. If it just blips lower.
Yeah, just that's a nice start. It could
totally just reverse up after that
though.
Would it suck to just get out
at break even? Yeah,
after all that. But
as a part of trading,
all right, we're I'm looking for this
move. It has stabbed through most of
this
move already, which is kind of rough.
But I can also if it starts to slow
down, I'll trail a little bit. Like I'll
trail previous candlestick.
I'm just going to give it a minute here
and see.
Got to manage my stupid recording pages.
Okay, I'm going to trail with two
with the previous candlestick.
That looks like it's just going to
basically not get knocked out.
O,
I really want to pull this down.
It literally just almost blipped it.
[Applause]
Okay, it filled that. My computer is
literally lagging.
Okay, I'm moving the rest down here.
to 2x.
I want to give it some room, but also
like
I'm not going to give it, you know,
crazy room here.
There we go. That's fine room right
there.
I'm going to give it I'm going to give
it this candlestick because it's clearly
ENQ hasn't even given the move back up.
Big picture. Pulling up the 15minute
chart again just to see where we're at.
Again, the easy money is kind of over.
But I don't So, and so it's like I'm
giving it some room, but also like I'm
not going to give it like one, you know,
a crazy amount. Like this is the move
I'm really looking for. I'm not really
looking for this. Like that's more if it
just rips lower,
you know?
[Applause]
Sick trade
that just came out of nowhere. I was not
expecting that to happen after this
chop. I was like, I'm screwed. I've lost
for the day.
Um,
well, okay. Okay. So, the market has
been open for 15 minutes here and
looking at the NASDAQ futures and the ES
futures. The NASDAQ has a pretty good
uptrend in place as well with the ES.
And so I would say there isn't really
great constructive support levels. You
know, we might come down here and
bounce. Looks like we're kind of selling
off right now, but if you look at both
of them, we had a really nice move up
yesterday in a sell-off,
but right now it's just kind of chopping
um in this bigger sideways trend still.
NASDAQ has broken out a little bit more.
Um so it it's definitely looking on the
bullish side overall, but also kind of
weak at the same time. And so in my
eyes, that's kind of just indecision.
and so makes me less likely to want to
touch it. Um, gold here is having a
kind of zoomed out on a 15 is having a
big move up here. It's kind of been
chopping around for a while, but now
it's had a big move yesterday and this
morning it's having a second one um and
going down to a fivem minute. Like this
is a nice uptrend that I would love to
try and short, but the problem is if we
zoom out to like a 30, there's just not
a great
level that it's at yet. You know, I'd
love it was if it was popping up here,
here there it's, you know, kind of had
some chop and there's some previous
tops over here,
but it's still just not great. And so
I'll look at it and see, you know, watch
it and see, okay, well, does it set up a
really nice clean looking like double
top kind of situation where I can at
least catch a move down to here,
especially like maybe on a one minute
chart if it looks like it'll reverse a
little quicker.
And then oil is just kind of crappy
looking. Um, it's just kind of in the
middle of the zone. Maybe if it pops
down to here, but at the moment its
current trend is just kind of just a
sloppy downtrend. You know, that's not
interesting. You know, I want to see
something overextended
and, you know, popping up a bunch of
fair value gap indicators on like a
50-minute chart. Um, like oil, I mean,
gold here. I mean, this is that's that
was a 30 minute technically, but you
know, again, very one directional
getting overextended. It's going to have
to have a pullback at some point. That's
the main thing. There's also
some news
30 minutes after the market opens. Uh,
in terms of of severity, it says it's
orange. I think this one actually is.
Um, Richmond m
Richmond manufacturing index is actually
green from my
sheet. So theoretically it's not that
big of a deal. Um but it will be up here
in like 10 minutes. So I'm kind of
waiting to see that. See if we can get a
reversal
in the NASDAQ. I think that's kind of
the biggest option at the moment. Um
especially after this reversing off of
that because we're just kind of in a
sideways range. There's also this low.
They're not great lows to be reversing
off of because we haven't like tested it
multiple times.
But with these early morning reversals,
sometimes that's all you need. And so
I'm okay watching that and taking a
quick stab on those on a one minute
chart.
Okay, this has sold off really fast on
the NASDAQ. And generally when this
happens, it could Vbottom and I'll
totally miss it. But also, we've broken
below this low. I like we could totally
get a failed breakout here, but I want
to see if I'm gonna take a long, I need
to see how it comes up and tests this
level because otherwise it could just
come up here and keep selling off. And
with when there's this much momentum in
in this case, it's you don't want to
just try and jump in long out of the
fear that oh there's, you know, a ton of
cra this crazy move down and I can, you
know, catch the whole swing up kind of
thing. That's not what we're looking
for.
I didn't get long on this initial candle
because I it just needs to kind of break
with the overall
bullishness or or bearishness happening.
I almost need like a higher low here.
Even though this is technically a higher
low,
just having a little bit more
confirmation would be good. Um
the sizing here isn't
great.
for
half size. I'll probably double the
contracts to go like 600 risk which
would end up being like 700.
But I mean overall like
just doesn't look great. And this is how
you weed out crappy or not great trades
when you're unsure.
But if this comes down here and pops up,
I want to get long.
And I think I want to get long two
contracts
because that's what I was just looking
for. And I think that's a good enough
confirmation.
You know, I'll be nervous about it
because
I'm a little back and forth on the read,
but I think this is a good spot to jump
in long because of this double bottom we
have. We've hit a
a low from I think this is couple days
ago kind of Friday.
Um
and so we are in long. Just going to
pull my stop up below this double bottom
and I'm probably just going to go for
2x here. Um just because the market is
pretty choppy.
I'm just going to switch up this
indicator here.
I'm kind of having some issues with it
lately just to show my actual
risk and profit. So, I'm I'm smaller
size than normal, kind of halfsized.
Um mainly because this was pretty
bearish move and
the level is
it's it's like kind of like the first
retest. But what I like is we have these
fair value gap indicators on a fivem
minute and the timing with 8:00 reversal
is pretty solid and then a double bottom
here. And so I think it looks good for a
nice move up.
And I'm only going to go for 2x just
because
of this bearishness that we're having.
Um also I've been sleeping like crap. So
um I just won't be making as good
decisions tech potentially.
This is just a pullback. I'm probably
going to have to hold back. Hold
through. I mean, I think with the with
the way this trend is, it needs to have
this double bottom and then some kind of
fake lower.
Um, once this kind of breaks up here, I
think to break to 1x here, I'll probably
move here and maybe break even if this
really looks like it's going to start to
get going. Um, just cuz I think it's
either it's this is a really nice
constructive setup now. And I think it's
either it's probably going to rip back
up here or it's going to come up here at
50% here and and continue lower with the
big picture bearishness
taken into a play. And you know, again,
I'm just looking for this quick reversal
in the morning. Um, and I don't want to
put risk on the table if it's just going
to not really do what I want it to do.
I will say this does not look great.
part of me wants to
move my stop up here,
take the risk off
because we haven't had a fast bounce
and it feels like it seems like the
downtrend could pick up. But also
in terms of big picture five minute
We can still totally come down here
and bounce on a fivem minute on there,
five minute on here. I mean, like, it
would still be totally intact. Um, and
then if I got out at break even and I
saw a bullish candlestick form right
here,
I'd be like, "Oh, I wish I was in that."
Because it it set up a very clean double
bottom on a fivem minute. And so I just
have to even though I'm feeling that
doubt and nervousness because it is kind
of choppy.
Um I'm just going to hold and because
the main big picture of the trade isn't
violated yet.
Is there the risk that it goes down?
Yes. And I lose? Yes.
But I don't want to get out because I'm
nervous
when there's no real market reason to
get out. You know, riskreward is there.
Um, and the big picture of of moving up
and giving back that snap down we had
from the market open is totally
possible. And so, you know, I think once
we break this is pretty much like a
little double top right here. Once we
break that,
I will move to break even at that point
because at that point it's it's had its
pullback that it should have in an
uptrend
and I'll want to get out at that point.
But right now it's just had this is the
first push higher and it could continue
higher after a pullback. Like a NASDAQ
here made a new high versus the ES
actually didn't. It basically made a
double top. Um, so just kind of waiting
for that to play out and
that's kind of the hard part about
trading.
Okay, we're getting a pop here. So, I'm
going to move to break even. Now,
sometimes I would move to the this low,
but if it pulls back off of that, I'm
just going to get out. Um, NASDAQ is
similar
five minutes like this is the five
minute pullback I was looking for. Like
I would have still wanted to been been
in if I got scared and got out there.
You know, the trade wasn't violated. Um,
with the way the market is, it could
still just
pull back and knock me out of break
even. But again,
just managing it. I don't know what's
going to happen. I would love to take
2x,
but we'll just have to see.
So, as this gets going here and I get
close to this 2x target, I'm going to
especially once we get up to here, like
once we start getting a candle up here
up to this price somewhere, I'm going to
move my stop loss up pretty aggressively
because there's no point in letting it
come up here and then rip all the way
back down, right? I'd rather just try
and get 2x at the most, but if it's just
going to come up here and pull back, I'd
rather just get out at like one and a
half. Um because this is a big move up
in, you know, a quick move to give this
back up, which is great, but it's been
kind of a a slow market. And so this
could really just reverse anytime at now
at this point. Um I you know it looks
really good to keep going higher. But
again big picture 50% pullback is um
based on this is just this dot right
here is literally right here on the
NASDAQ. So we're at the 50%. Um and ES
is
past the 50%. So,
I would love for this to keep going
higher. And I think if that's going to
happen, it's got this tight trend that
it's going to hold. And so, I'm going to
move up actually to 1x here. I really
almost don't want to because I don't
want it to come down here, knock me out,
and keep going higher.
But in terms of managing it tightly and
having this more fixed riskreward of
well I I only have a little bit more
profit to make. There's no point in you
know risking essentially $1,000
um to make you know another $400. That's
kind of how the math adjusts as your
trade goes. Um and so
I don't want to give all that back up.
Um, and and it doesn't make sense
mathwise. Um, and so hopefully it holds
this, but again, it looks like it could
just have a pullback here. Um, and you
know, I could have it down here, but you
know what? I am I'm still happy if I get
1x on a trade. Um, it's a long, which is
harder to play. It was half size, so I
wasn't really super confident in it to
begin with. Um,
and so I can be super bummed, but I'll
be a little bummed just because it does
look good. But again, it's it's given
back a lot of the move and it's not the
market's just not acting great in terms
of strength. Um, NASDAQ here, that's a
little bit nicer of a bottom to hold.
Um, but again, like I think this is ES
is going to hold this and and keep going
higher if it's going to hold. But this
uptrend is already kind of broken.
So
five minute NASDAQ just looks cleaner.
But again, this is this is where I'm at.
Okay, out for 700.
Still happy about it. Still a nice
trade. you know jumped in smaller size
because of
how I felt about it and you know if it
if it just shoots lower here I will be
very happy that I got out
you know I don't want to play this
struggle game of waiting for it to
continue higher slowly over and over
time not every day is going to be you
know amazing follow your strategy go
with what your read is that's all you
can do and so make sure to download that
14page free candle stick patterns guide
in the link in the description of this
video or with this QR code right here.
It'll really help you consistently
execute this strategy and show you more
patterns that I use to enter in on other
than the quick ones I just went through.